I think too many women get stuck in this.
I'm a bad bitch. I'm a bad bitch.
I'm a bad bitch. Can't nobody hurt me. Nobody hurt me.
That you're forgetting you're a fucking human and you have feelings.
And it's okay to cry. It's okay to cry that some guy hurt you.
It's okay to fucking admit, yeah,
he pumped and dumped, and here I am,
and now I'm crying. And it's okay.
Because the only way you're gonna learn from your fucking lesson
is if you actually admit that you had a fucking problem.
If everything has gone fine for you and you're a bad bitch
and nothing ever hurt you, nobody.
You're feeling that. How are you ever gonna learn and grow?
You have to acknowledge and admit that, like,
I got. I got played.
Damn it, that one hurt.
I feel stupid. You're not stupid,
but you feel that way.
And you have to admit it and acknowledge it so you can move on from it.
Otherwise, it's gonna be, like,
holding you back.
And you're always gonna have this little voice in your head saying, yep,
that one time you got played.
But that one time, that guy did it.
You gotta, like,
clear the shit out so you can move forward.
You can't move forward when you're holding onto the past.
When you're, like,
acting like nothing ever happened.
All you've done is brush it under the rug,
so it's still fucking there.
I'm Pretty sure you're gonna have a mountain
with just a rug covering it.
Do you know what I'm saying? Like it's a fucking okay.
It's okay to not be okay.